we want her to have a sibling because
she has such interesting circumstances
to grow up in anyway so it would be nice
to be able to share it with somebody
that was Hoda Kotb just last month
playing coy when each he asked if she
planned on giving her little girl a
sibling
now it's official Jota has welcomed baby
number two just two years after the
Today Show co-hosts adopted her first
daughter hailey joy Hoda announced
through an emotional live phone call on
the morning show that she and her
partner Joel Schiffman have adopted a
second daughter hope Katherine hobby oh
my god you guys first of all I'm she's
laying on the Boppy pillow right now and
my god I'm cheating her but also gushed
over how her two-year-old took to her
role as big sis I'm dying
we had hailey downstairs and Joel and I
said wait what then we have a present
and we came down holding her and we've
been telling her baby hopes coming and
she literally walked up to her and goes
and look difference goes oh oh but it
gets even cuter guys this morning at
breakfast she was trying to feed her you
know her raspberries and I was like not
yet babe she was literally marching
around saying I'm a big sister like I
mean she did try to crawl into her
bassinet
so the 54 year olds also reveal the
significance behind little hopes middle
name and we named her middle name
Katherine after my best friend Karen
who's her daughter first you know I
think you guys know that her her husband
passed a little while ago and Katherine
is so super strong
and just so happens she was here this
weekend with Karen and I was like you
know what there are no accidents in life
what everything is supposed to happen in
this moment the way it's happening
but anyway so hope Kathryn coffee
how sweet is that now Jota is just the
cutest mama there ever was and get this
she said it's hard for her to believe
how lucky she is you think that you're
full why do you think that you're full
that's exactly how I felt with Haley and
Joel and everything and Jo and I were
standing there when they hand you the
baby and it's the closest thing to a
live birth I think he'll ever see but
anyway in that moment I was like oh my
god amazing
anyway I I can't believe it's happening
this is the kind of news that we love to
hear first thing in the morning and we
want to send our heartfelt congrats to
Hoda and her sweet congratulations
of course we will keep you updated on
all things Hoda so be sure to keep it
locked on et until next time I'm
Courtney teza know and I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
you